we're gonna do a hard segue off this
topic because someone just uh because i
want to but someone also chatted biden
is a blank okay good enough for me
so uh i saw this tweet and a lot of
other people were commenting something
similar this is president biden tweeting
i'm fighting every day to pass my build
back better agenda for folks like
brandon his story is like so many i've
heard across the country folks are just
looking for a fighting chance and to be
treated with the dignity they deserve
and that's what my agenda is all about i
saw this video and my first reaction was
they're trying to hijack let's go
brandon
and
there's a disabled man named brandon
saying thank you joe biden for a build
back better it's because of this plan i
can keep you know my living assistance
and i'm like that's just wrong this poor
guy this poor guy first of all he didn't
pass bill back better it's not going to
happen manchin and cinema are saying no
and it really feels like this was a pr
campaign because let's go brandon for
those that don't know means f joe biden
and it's viral
it's viral
sports games colleges
uh apparently i was reading like people
at a gun range were yelling it yeah that
one's obvious so viral it's generating
apparently fake news stories out of
canada which was some government agency
out of canada saying in a formal memo
that you're not allowed seeing let's go
brandon or any variation thereof yeah
apparently it turned out to be fake but
uh it's my number one t-shirt seller my
let's go brandon sure it's the number
one that people are buying more than
anyone else so this has caught on like
wildfire now it means this nice little
disabled guy right gop congressman ends
floor speech with let's go brandon
florida rep bill posey signed off with a
fist pump spicy yeah there's songs at
the top of the charts talking about it i
mean this says caught on and there's
something to say about this brilliant
but what's actually terrible is you're
not allowed saying it in certain places
or it's become taboo where uh
canada oh no
yeah you don't say because it's a
political statement now
they still can't save for this guy his
name may very well be brandon and now
nobody can cheer him on right
you say hijacking it might just be
co-opting or they might want to flip it
around where now whenever they say let's
go brandon it's going to have a positive
tone that biden's going to be able to
say look yup they're cheering on my
campaign
could you imagine if biden ends up doing
a video where you or like jen sackey
they'll like a clip of people going
let's go brandon you know and then she's
gonna be like people are really picking
up our campaign they're really excited
well it's memes come to life because you
know there's all the memes of biden
talking to obama saying they're cheering
his name they're doing all these things
they they want to have sex with him
that's what it all means and now it's
going to be for real life no trump would
have never made this mistake just
because the association is biden with
disability in such a way that you know i
don't know if i would associate myself
in that way i feel bad for the guy man
yeah he's just being completely
manipulated
he's being used he's being exploited for
an aspect of identity politics that's
just it's just cheap politics just
bring up people to garner sympathy but
also it's going to reflect poorly on
biden that's for sure it remind
everybody of it i mean why don't remind
somebody if something is a weakness
right yeah that's what trump was really
good at completely don't talk about you
know rope in a house with has been a
hanging yeah yeah yeah and that's why he
would label people with names yes sleepy
joe
crooked hillary crooked hillary uh what
was the other one there for bush bush
was low energy low energy
and then my favorite was when uh the
trump's reporters turned lion like lying
into lion like rar
they were like he's lying ted but it's
the good one now pretty clever
well you know little marco
little marco marco man trump was good at
it he was he's right and that we all
remember them without much help is
amazing how the branding worked so this
is interesting though trump was really
good at meaning
like the naming people even now with
trump you know kind of behind the scenes
doing the trump social stuff
people have just created another meme
that's gone viral and everyone's
laughing and loving it and i think when
you see the uh we pulled up the civics
uh polling
joe biden's approval rating among
independent voters is 26 percent
well he's just thinking like remarkably
bad terrible terrible i mean when you
see football games and they're chanting
let's go brandon like these are regular
people these are not political
individuals well the last time we saw
this kind of same similar culture
jamming was with jeffrey epstein with
the memes with the messaging everyone's
screaming jeffrey epstein did not uh
kill himself do something to himself and
obviously but that caught on everywhere
on national television people
interrupted broadcasts people were
bringing it up in just the most weirdest
random points and and that caught on
because there was this a major
disassociation from the mainstream from
the narrative from of course everything
the establishment wanted you to know and
think about and then people saying hey
we're actually paying attention here
you're full of crap we're going to let
you know about it by putting this into
the culture so this is another example
of this on another level which is pretty
pretty awesome and interesting to see
for the one viewer out there who might
not know the whole story it's brandon
brown from nascar wins the nascar and
everyone in the background chanting f
joe biden and the reporter says hey you
hear them saying let's go brandon wow
it's the simpsons again
the future the simpsons have done it
time and time again here it's boo worms
right right
it would be a joke if it weren't so darn
funny actually i got to tell you man
i keep seeing posts where it's like we
live in a simulation because it's just
become so
a life is a parody of itself at this
point how stupid everything's become
they call it a simulacrum where there's
like it's like a false
essence of a simulation they're showing
you they're like actively trying to show
you a fake reality
let's go brandon and are they it was so
obvious that they were trying to be like
oh what do we do when i was i was on
newsmax with sean spicer's show and they
were like they played the clip and you
hear beep joe biden
i'm laughing because i'm like the beeps
because like we know what they're saying
i just i'm just imagining now like
i'm sorry this campaign they're doing
with with this disabled guy
it seems so obvious it's cheap and
exploitive but i will say i will say i
would not be surprised if biden comes
out and tries claiming the let's go
brandon chance are for him now yeah yeah
because because look
the people who support the democrats
are are not going to back away from that
and they'll be like see and you'll be
like guys it's not true
every time a story comes out about trump
and it's proven to be false or fouchy
lies to congress and then you get all
these democrats on reddit and twitter
being like aha facie's so smart and you
prove it's wrong they don't accept
reality they just point to you and say
you're a q a on conspiracy theorists and
i'm like bro i got i don't know anything
about those guys but i'll tell you this
they're not the ones in in cnn they're
not the ones in the white house or
congress maybe like one or two people if
you want to be very critical but y'all
like all of you except for like a very
small faction are totally in on this
insanity this fake news well it's just
redefining language i mean it's to the
point where fully vaccinated is now not
going to mean fully vaccinated within a
couple of weeks well well hold on
what does fully vaccinated even really
mean uh the cdc
definition or the the real life
definition that other countries are
using because there's a difference well
so now university of denver is going to
mandate the flu vaccine nope so if
they're like are you fully vaccinated
it's like well look me personally i've
got a bunch of vaccines so many so i
don't know what full counts to you but
you know though to drop a little quebec
uh politics francoise ago the premier of
quebec when he tweeted it out he didn't
use fully vaccinated he used it was in
french adequate vaccine adequately
vaccinated which i which i uh pointed
out that's great that's nice fluff talk
there because that means two doses is
not going to be enough very soon no
there's no question it's going to be
it's going to be a constantly evolving
term and it's going to be absorbing
other vaccines and other issues now the
government knows it can mandate what it
can put into your body and it's going to
expand into other issues as well the
other day luke claimed that bill gates
was funding a microchip that can make
you fertile or that could turn on and
off fertility through a touch of a
button and i told him he was crazy until
i googled it and it's true alex jones
bill gates funded uh um implantable uh
contraceptive
contraceptive right
microchip but it's a contraceptive that
you can control with an app and so
actually that
innocently you know sounds great right
an individual who wants to you know a
woman or a presumably a guy wants to go
on birth control they can just turn
their phone on and then when they won't
have kids they can turn it off but you
know just sounds so nefarious when you
think about it yeah you know bill gates
and other people who believe in
population control also having the
ability to turn people's fertility on
and off you know there's nothing wrong
with that
it's just you take the chinese social
credit model and you apply it much
broadly because i mean what he did in
india in terms of controlling people's
biometric identification purposes of
financial access for transportation for
travel you just add vaccinations one
child policy
what you guys need to understand what
people need to understand is when you go
on twitter and you see the woke left the
establishment democrats
that is the social credit system they
are currently living in it
and so that's why a lot of people won't
speak out there there may be people
watching right now who are like i can't
stand what's happening around me but i'm
not going to say anything
congratulations you live in the social
credit system the only thing you're
missing is the app so they can read your
your your score but if you're going to
abide by all of their rules and adhere
to all of it that's it well there
already is a social credit score but
it's not like the the people in china
have to deal with it's a corporate one
here when many corporations have at
almost every
aspect of your existence
written down recorded and then they have
a certain score that they allocate you
on how many advertisements they could
sell you but also your political stances
what you believe in where you should be
ranked in the algorithm how much you
should be promoted where you're going to
land on the news feed even if you're
going to be shown on the news feed so
there's already a social credit score
here in the united states with many
multinational corporations that have
implemented it with real life
consequences because people speak wrong
think and get punished for it thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you